ich würde ganz kurz stoppen ich danke
dir
ich beschreibe dir mal ganz kurz was wir
sehen können und zwar wird gerade die
straße gesperrt wo der charité navalny
kommt jetzt hier vermutlich gleich wir
sehen die ersten motorräder die ersten
polizei motorräder und die kolonne kommt
wahrscheinlich hier an du siehst das
bild der suche dir trotzdem zu
beschreiben genau was kannst du dazu
kommentieren
also es ist so dass auch dort das bka
das bundeskriminalamt die führung
übernommen hat das ist den aktivisten
komplett entrissen worden
denn natürlich gibt es eine große angst
davor oder man muss so eine
sicherheitslage vorbereiten wir dürfen
ja eins nicht vergessen auch in
deutschland hat es nicht nur er hat es
einen tiergarten mord gegeben wo
nachweisbar russische agenten jemanden
einen tschetschenischen aktivisten
umgebracht haben also der russische
staat oder der kreml der geheimdienst
ist auch oder besonders in berlin aktiv
und unabhängig davon geht es natürlich
darum jetzt allerdings sicher in die
charité zu bringen ich kenne dort die
charité ganz gut denn ich habe vor zwei
jahren den pussycat aktivisten peter
vaerst sie lockt dort interviewt nachdem
auch er vergiftet worden war einige
werden sich erinnern
er wird dort in einen abgesperrten
bereich kommen eine
hochsicherheitsbereich kann man sagen um
dort behandelt zu werden um dort
natürlich auch die behandlung zu
bekommen die wofür die charité so
berühmt ist wir kennen den professor ein
häufig in diesem fall soll es jemand
anders sein aber natürlich ist die hat
die charité da einen ganz ganz großen
namen und ist sicherlich auch stolz ein
wenig dass jedes mal wenn es um alles
geht wenn vergiftungs opfer eine klinik
suchen aufgesucht werden
dieser bereich wird abgesperrt sein das
wird ein hochsicherheitsbereich sein wo
jetzt navalny behandelt wird und wo auch
die entscheidenden fragen gestellt
werden und hoffentlich antworten das
hoffentlich auch antworten dazu gibt was
das für ein gespannt was da möglich
passiert ist
und wir sehen jetzt auch noch ich
beschreibe die noch mal kurz das bild
also es sind jetzt die große kohle ist
vorbei gefahren wir sind gerade relativ
nah drauf auf einem transportwagen
vielleicht ist das auch genau der wagen
in dem navalny gerade ist ja und wir
haben auch gesehen auf der straße war
einiges los natürlich sind viele
journalisten vor ort aber auch einige
schaulustige haben wir gerade gesehen
die ihre smartphones hoch gehalten haben
und die vorbeifahrt gedreht haben also
es ist wirklich ein fall der ganz
normale bevölkerung hier interessiert
man muss eins ganz klar sagen die welt
schaut heute morgen auf berlin
alle internationalen medienberichten ich
bin hier um geben auch mit vielen
reportern aus der ganzen welt die wir
heute nicht so sehr auf mich schauen
zumindest in diesen stunden sondern sich
fragen was passiert da in berlin
wie geht s navalny was passiert dort und
die in diesen sekunden in diesen minuten
auf die charité blicken was dort
passiert und man kann ja auch wirklich
nur hoffen dass die experten dort es
schaffen ihn wieder die augen zu öffnen
dass er überlebt also vor allem
natürlich für seine familie
aber er ist ja auch ein vorreiter und
ein riesen vorbild für ganz ganz viele
menschen du hast es auch gerade gesagt
das ist ein wahnsinnig mutige politiker
magst du uns noch mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen warum das heute wirklich
ein weltereignis ist nun ja es geht
darum das ist natürlich in den
vergangenen den vergangenen tag ein
remis gegeben hat um die frage lässt
putin derweil die überhaupt ausweisen
ich weiß von verschiedenen quellen dass
auch deutsche spitzenpolitiker einfluss
genommen haben dass die versucht haben
die russische seite davon zu überzeugen
ihn fliegen zu lassen
auf der anderen seite gab es natürlich
zwischen den russischen quellen die
debatte und die frage was passiert
werden wir ihn jetzt sofort fliegen
lassen bedeutet dass man kann ein
mögliches gift nachweisen also das
scheint die entscheidende frage hier
gewesen zu sein auf das was da war
ehefrau dann dort gesagt hat dass man
befürchtet dass russland möglicherweise
ihnen eben nicht sofort fliegen lassen
wollte weil es dann ein gift
nachgewiesen werden könnte zum
hintergrund warum ist es am ende die
charité geworden ich weiß von dem
aktivisten jaka bizilj das ist ein anruf
gab gestern morgen nachdem das passiert
ist nachdem die vergiftung stattgefunden
hat zwei tages mittlerweile her also vor
zwei tagen am morgen ob er helfen kann
und zwar vom peter vaerst elop den pussy
leid aktivisten der 2018 genau dort wo
wir jetzt die autos sehen auch behandelt
wurde in der berliner charité und der
dort so gut behandelt worden werden
konnte dass es ihm heute wieder gut geht
also dieser peter werth hat dann die
aktivisten von cinema for peace gefragt
ob sie wieder helfen können und die
haben dann innerhalb von stunden ein
flieger organisiert haben alle
genehmigungen bereitstellen können und
dann gab es diesen wahlprozess diesen
jimmy der dort in russland passiert ist
wo sich deutsche spitzenpolitiker
eingeschaltet haben werke der
französische staatspräsident markt
ebenfalls der übrigens angeboten hatte
dass dabei möglicherweise auch nach
paris gebracht werden konnte aber man
hat sich für berlin entschieden